As soon as one artillery round
blasts toward Bakhmut,
the crew rushes to prepare for another
Ukrainian officials report
gains in the town.
That since last year has been
the epicenter of the war.
Gun Commander
Artem has been in the area for months,
reaching the task of taking down
coordinates and barking orders.
Now, routine
He says he's now
half deaf from the blast.
Yet he has sense to change.
It seems like they're often running away,
he says, referring to the Russians.
And then the order to fire
There's barely
a let up in the distant third shelling
target.
The Russian
says this gunner call sign
Aries are falling back.
We know because they hit us, much less.
One or two months ago,
there was a lot of incoming.
It was scary to be here.
Now it's different
On another flank, the big guns are out.
This is a book, Dana.
A Ukrainian made 155 millimeters
self-propelled Howitzer
Ukraine claims the Russians have poured
as many as 50,000 troops into the defense
of the town, dug in deep Russian.
It was only the Russians
who fortified their positions
and stand strong, Commander
Dmitry tells me.
But I think that's temporary.
Russian soldiers captured in the battle
here told us
the shelling on their positions
was relentless warfare.
That was a
high explosive anti-personnel munition
fired at the direction of Russian troops
outside of Bakhmut.
As soon as they fired,
they prepare to fire again.
Now, it appears that the Ukrainians
are really pulling out
all the stops around Bakhmut.
Over the months,
I've been covering the battle
in and around that town.
I've always heard the Ukrainians complain
about a shortage of ammunition.
We didn't hear that today.
They seem to have more than enough.
One of those batteries told us
that they're firing
50, 6100 rounds a day.
It really does appear
that Bakhmut is at the moment
the focus of this Ukrainian
counter-offensive Wolf.
Very interesting.
Ben Wedeman, stay safe over there.
Thank you very much.
Right now,
let's bring in
CNN contributor on Russian affairs,
Jill Dougherty and CNN military analyst
retired Colonel Cedric Leighton.
Colonel Leighton,
now that Ukraine will be receiving
these u.s.-made cluster bombs
How will they leverage those weapons
in their counter offensive right now
while limiting Syria's collateral damage?
You can see in this video
of a Russian attack on Kharkiv.
The bombs don't always
detonate immediately
Yeah, that's going to be a
big challenge for them both.
But the basic premise
behind the Ukrainian effort
to get cluster munitions
is that they will use them
against the trenches that the Russians
have drawn up
all throughout the eastern front
as well as the southern front.
So if they do that
and if they limit
the target area
of those cluster munitions,
they might be able to limit
the civilian exposure to them once
this war is over.
Jill, you're an expert on Russia.
We know Russia has been using
these cluster bombs
against Ukrainians for some time.
How are they reacting to this news
that the US is about to provide
these cluster munitions
to the Ukrainians?
You know, Wolf,
I've been looking at several stories
in the Russian media and every single one
immediately jumps on the admission
by the Biden administration
that these weapons are,
you know, dangerous
for civilians, civilians,
or at least they can be.
And then also, I think significantly
they're saying,
hey, look, the United States and Ukraine
never signed
the international conventions
about these weapons, ignoring the fact
and not including the fact
that Russia hasn't either.
And then again,
noting that
the Ukrainians are using these weapons,
this ammunition in Ukraine right now,
leaving out the fact that Russia is so
what they're doing is it's obviously part
of the propaganda approach
and just trying to take advantage of it
and make the United States look very bad
for making that decision.
And Jill, let me follow up.
The U.S.
says the NATO members
who will be meeting next week
at the summit in Lithuania
will not admit Ukraine to the alliance,
at least not yet.
But how much does any progress toward
that goal actually feed Putin's anxiety
Well,
he obviously does not want any expansion
of NATO whatsoever.
But I think what
the Russians are trying to do
is exploit any division among the allies
or between the allies.
So this issue of,
you know, should Sweden join?
Obviously, Finland already is.
But Sweden is a big issue.
And because there are differences
in terms of Ukraine,
whether Ukraine should
ultimately be given
any type of promise or indication
that it could be a member,
that's where the Russians
are going to try to exploit
as much as possible any type of division.
So what Naito is trying to do,
obviously, is figure out
how it can give security guarantees
to Ukraine, which are crucial,
and then how they can present
something to Ukraine
that would be forward
looking in terms of possible membership.
You know, it's interesting,
Colonel Leighton,
the NATO's summit will also focus,
we're told, on long term
security assistance for Ukraine,
including F-16 fighter jets.
What should be prioritized right now
based on what you know
about Ukraine's capabilities,
at least at this moment?
Well, I think, Wolf, one of the key
things is watching
the military speak
is called interoperability.
And that is the idea
that Ukrainian systems
should be able to talk to NATO's
weapons systems.
So anything that they can be made to work
together in the sense
that in a doctrinal sense,
that is exactly what the NATO's
meeting should actually result in.
And if they can do that with F-16s,
that will allow
a great deal of interoperability
between the Ukrainian Air Force
and NATO's air forces.
That would be one
step in that direction
and also long range weapons
that could be interoperable
between those areas.
That would be another
plus for the Ukrainians.
Colonel Leighton and Jill Dougherty,
guys, thank you very much.